joining me now is Simon Balmain he's a
Twitter employee but has found himself
locked out of his work laptop today
hello to you Simon thanks for joining us
tell us what's happened in the last 24
hours or so to you and to your
colleagues sure so
um we sort of started hearing strong
rumors about about layoffs a few days
ago
um which I'm sure everybody heard about
because it you know it leaked quite
quickly to the breast
um late last night we all received an
email saying you know there is going to
be a large reduction in head count
um and the email stated that uh if we
would be laid off we'd hear from our to
our personal email and if not to our
work email and it was about an hour
after that and this is in the early
hours of the morning UK like 2 A.M
um that I noticed my work laptop was
remotely wiped
um and my email access and slack access
were both revoked
um and then got in touch with a few
colleagues and it seems a lot of people
were saying the same thing so that's
that's what happened
uh and how do you feel Simon obviously
you still haven't received official word
as to whether you're going to lose your
job or not
um how are you feeling
yeah a bit of a weird mix of emotions of
you know uh you really enjoyed working
at Twitter it's it's been incredible
um but
you know this this acquisition has been
unprecedented in about a million
different ways
um as everybody's been following along
with over the last few months and
um you know every every day is is
something new and a new corner is turned
and we you know have all been trying to
deal with it as best we can
um I'm generally a pretty Zen pretty
optimistic person so I'm I'm pretty okay
actually you know regardless of of what
happens
um
it's it's been sad I think
um
there's a lot of interesting projects
that have been in the works at Twitter
to different degrees prior to this
acquisition my my biggest thing is like
if a lot of those projects Now sort of
get the development get stopped and they
they don't really see a wide release
um in favor of new things then that's
understandable but it's also a real
shame because there was stuff with real
potential going on
there are suggestions uh that as many as
half uh the 7 000 strong Workforce could
lose their jobs uh later today and of
course there's been a lot of uncertainty
hanging over Twitter lately hasn't there
with the purchase by Elon Musk not
knowing whether it would happen or not
and then of course um he's made some
rather bold statements in terms of what
he wants to do with the company since
taking over what is morale like among
the workforce
yeah it's it's been kind of all over the
place it's been a roller coaster ever
since April when he sort of first made
the offer then throughout the summer
with this you know lawsuit and you know
changing his mind and then you know it
looked at the last minute you know when
the court case was set to happen he
obviously changes my back and I wanted
to do the deal and has not done the deal
so it really has been
um difficult for people to really stay
focused
um not knowing what's going to happen I
mean the the communication throughout
was
very much always along the lines of
we'll tell you when we know more and
then that was just an ongoing thing sort
of week after week month after month
um
I personally try to keep my head down
and focus on the work but um it's
definitely been incredibly distracting
over the last few months for sure
obviously you know moth did pay an
enormous amount of money for Twitter 44
billion dollars uh he is now trying to
make the company profitable uh where job
Cuts expected
yeah I think so I I think it would be
naive to um to not have have seen that
coming given everything that was
reported about the economics of the deal
and the fact that he was trying to get
out of it for so long and
um then was sort of had to do it whether
that was completely of his own volition
or whether because he felt the you know
the outcome of the court case would not
be in his favor you know whatever
reasons those may be the deal was
completed and at the original price and
um yeah I think layoffs were inevitable
to a degree to I think to some degree
um
layoffs were probably inevitable
regardless even if the deal hadn't
happened I'm not sure what the final
amount would be it probably would have
been lower if if this acquisition hadn't
happened
um
because it's put a lot on the balance
sheet of him and the company
um so yeah it's it's just a weird one
uh well we do appreciate you uh speaking
to us that what must be a pretty
stressful time uh thank you very much
pleasure indeed for speaking to
assignment and we wish you well with
whatever happens later on today thank
you so much cheers